okay doing the set up slightly different
this time trying to get better angle and
everything and that did stall me
slightly getting this sucker going
alright so is this actually working or
is it just gonna be a jerk on me we
shall see it's hard to know sometimes
evening okay good so I guess we're live
then cool don't you love how every live
stream ever in the history of live
streams basically starts with are we
live are we live
can someone tell me can you hear me it's
uh it's a bit of a cliche but I sadly
necessary one hi everybody I'm gonna
tilt this a little bit more like I said
slightly different angle so just trying
to Center myself a bit better there we
go
hi but yes I enjoy this shirt quite a
bit ah is this thing on yeah yeah pretty
much
hey Casteel dynamic angle yeah I'm
having I'm having fun changing things up
a little bit in a few ways how have
things been good I am sorry for missing
the live stream last week but I was just
honestly I wasn't feeling up to it I
don't want that to read like uh I was
depressed I don't like it I'm not gonna
say you don't have my bad days but I
don't like have diagnose depression I'm
not like oh I had a bad mental holiday
was nothing like that I was physically
fine I just I was too drained by life
I just didn't it felt like it felt like
too much work to do and I don't want
that to sound like it wouldn't have been
worth it but just this doesn't normally
feel like work when I do this so you
know the prospect of doing it when it
did feel like work kind of yeah I didn't
want to I don't want to break my my
enjoyment of doing this by allowing it
to become work and I hoped the feeling
faded and it did it so Cheers ah do you
have any specific educational background
or is there any feel you'd like to study
I don't know like how much I feel like I
mentioned this offhandedly more than a
few times but it's been sporadic across
videos I didn't finish college so I'm
from any academic standpoint I have
nothing to write home about I'm nothing
I've been nothing to brag about I don't
have I I mean like I finished high
school I did do several years of college
but I didn't finish and I don't plan to
go back and part of that is financial
like I like to take things like writing
classes and a few other things I suppose
if I did go back I go with a more than I
to probably probably finished the
English major that I started but you
know I what I enjoy doing I'm not sure
would benefit by all that much more of a
formal education than I've had I have to
read The Handmaid's Tale for my
literature class however I know very
little about it what about you I just
know the iconography of the TV show and
I know some of the themes in it I
haven't seen the show I haven't read the
book I can't help I cannot be your
CliffsNotes how dated is that reference
is CliffsNotes still a thing because I
feel like Wikipedia would have
completely obliterated their business
model
did you see philosophy tubes new video
he came out as bisexual I did it was a
very nice video he does really good work
he he rides the line really well because
he he comes right up to the edge of
overproducing in terms of the you know
the sets and the Lighting's and the
music but he manages to not quite step
over that line at least not for me he
comes close at times though it's kind of
fun to watch that high wire act any
other writers [ __ ] that's a good
question sparked notes well what is that
spark notes is more common now Cliff's
Notes is still on so what spark notes
and Cliff's Notes are this was this is
what we did before Wikipedia was so
ubiquitous if you wanted to know the
plot and themes of a book for the
purposes of passing an exam there were
basically little thin books to help you
do that neither Cliff's Notes or
sparknotes when I was in college
CliffsNotes was the bigger name so I
guess spark it sounds like spark no it's
a bypass them I ended up seeing the new
Maleficent movie on Saturday due to a
power outage I had to deal with it was
exactly what I thought it was going to
be utterly stupid I honestly I forgot
that movie came out I forgot that it was
going to come out and then it came out
and I forgot it came out some would say
poetry is passe but I feel there's a lot
to really admire about it even in the
monitor I'll poach is not passe the the
issue with poetry is it's a lot it is
both in a simultaneously both easier and
harder for poets to be noticed it's
easier in that there's a lot of mediums
through we should get your stuff known
if you can do if you do short form
poetry Twitter's actually pretty great
for that but the problem is it's a
completely open platform
the thing about poets you know when you
think Oh poets you know Walt Whitman and
you know the this sort of idealization
of poetry you need to realize the people
who like were poets professionally were
you know the the well-educated already
wealthy people they could afford to do
something as quote/unquote frivolous as
poetry not to save poor people couldn't
write poetry but they never had the
means to get theirs out there now anyone
has the means to get those out there but
that does mean the number the the odds
if you it used to be if you could get
poetry out there there was a pretty good
chance you could make some money on it
on this day these days it's so easy to
get out there the odds of it getting
noticed much are pretty slim notice me I
have noticed you have answered some of
your questions man do you have any
favorite after Halloween movies like for
me i rewatch hocus-pocus last time that
I immediately watch Miracle on 34th
Street um oh I never thought about like
an after Halloween movie no I have a
handful of of Halloween staples for me
but they are mostly either shows or
segments of movies so like the Garfield
Halloween special that's one it's a
great chunk is the Great Pumpkin Charlie
Brown that's another one The Legend of
Sleepy Hollow half of Ichabod and mr.
toad the Disney movie and also when
Christmas was sorry when Halloween was
forever which is a real Ghostbusters
episode and a great one I only accept
Vogon poetry would love to see your
thoughts on current wars especially
actors outside of theirs superhero roles
love you it's book nerd Oh 486 from
Twitter current Wars I'm is that an
autocorrect error or is that something
that I should know and don't I
I accept that either one of those as
possible both incredibly excited and
incredibly nervous about a quiet place
to next year I'm just nervous like any
like horror movie sequels just as a
thing seriously
first most fantastic what horror
seagulls can be kind of scheduled yeah
they can be very sketchy so tryna okay
ooh geez okay there's there's no pause
feature on the chat that I'm trying to
use to not get so far behind I'm still
figuring it out because tech doesn't
like me the other night I was dreaming
about McDonald's cheeseburgers maybe my
subconscious was hungry for fast food I
honestly don't know I don't know or
maybe you really wanted to rewatch Pulp
Fiction and have the Royale with cheese
conversation who knows I'm not um I'm
not one to read into dreams very much I
suppose that's probably partly because I
I don't remember very much of mine but
um I don't know are you hopeful about
queer representation in the MCU ah
hopeful is kind of an odd word I mean we
know it's happening we know it's coming
I mean at this point even if it's good
I'll be happy for that but I'm not gonna
be joyful or jumping from the rooftops
cuz it's yo it's been over 20 freaking
movies like it
I love the Marvel movies most of them
there's only a couple that I don't like
Denny's significant degree and but
honestly the first thing I will toss out
there is given how basically bulletproof
they are at the box office at this point
they play it very safe and given how
much box-office clout they had they
waited way oh geez that person a couple
of me I am so sorry they waited way way
way way too long to give us a superhero
who wasn't white a superhero was a male
any character that wasn't sis that
straight and now we're waiting for a
hero who was not sis that straight so
like I'm glad it's there but you know
this is that this is not a big cheering
thing cuz like you you had so much clout
like you couldn't they could have done
it way before this point so as a special
for Halloween can you murder ten people
on camera but expectedly um we just
settled for five I'm not sure I have the
time to do ten hyped for your second
Channel yeah okay so let me explain that
so I announced this on Twitter this okay
this was something that I had been
thinking about doing and then on a whim
I kind of just went with it last night
and put it live so there is now a second
channel it is directly related to this
one so it actually who a boy it actually
becomes a third Channel for me
well fourth really but for all intents
and purposes third Channel because the
other ones go a while but that's I mean
it's still me but it's very different
topic wise and I also have an update in
a while really need to anyways so
there's a second channel related to this
it's called break room of geeks break
room is two words and
what that is going to be I've actually
already kind of moved some stuff over
there to give you an idea of the sort of
stuff that I'm going to be putting over
there like I moved the let's plays over
there the fan video I did of Barbara
Kean the music video that I moved over
there and the first new thing that I put
up there was a reaction video to the
Dracula the BBC Dracula teaser um and
like a light like a proper reaction like
with the having the thing actually
showing while I'm talking about it
because the purpose of doing a second
channel is twofold
links in the description I actually have
got it there um so the the purpose for
watching a second channel is twofold the
first is that I can drop things that I
know we're gonna give me copyright
headache and aren't worth it to me to
bother fighting over there things like
reaction videos that's not to say I
won't still get copyright hassled here I
will but I'm gonna pick my battles over
here very specifically and there's a lot
of stuff I simply don't do just so I
don't have to battle up over it so
that's one thing that I'll end up over
there and the other thing is are things
that just wouldn't pull the the view
numbers because at this point the
channel is big enough that if I upload
something that does not do well view
wise if that happens enough that
actually hurts me in the algorithm and
it hurts the channels growth because as
far as YouTube is concerned I'm
uploading stuff that nobody wants to see
because the views are way down versus my
normal average so that's a big part of
why I like say the Let's Plays gonna
move because I would like to do more
Let's Plays but I can't put them on the
main channel
you know just gauging the interest level
off of them I can't put them on the main
channel without it hurting the channel
and because the channel is not big
enough to pay my bills yet I can't
afford to slow its growth for that so
the breakroom of geeks is going to serve
as a place whele
formal it's not gonna have a fixed
release schedule cuz main council geeks
still be four videos a week it's just
gonna be stuff that doesn't belong on
the other channel but I I'll still get
to do them and part of it is to
reinvigorate me because since I've had
tener I'm not necessarily narrow focus
but since I've had to sort of trim and
focus down for stuff that I do want to
do but is going to build well on the
channel it's made me a little more
cautious and a little less spontaneous
because being spontaneous potentially
costs me growth but now I've got a
second place where I can be silly and
stupid and spontaneous and not worrying
about it hitting me at all
so it's kind of a it's a little bit
energizing to get that going I will
grant humbled on a lot so hang on let me
back up it's a movie about the Doctor
Strange actor and the latest Superman
guy I'm gonna have to look this up
Rachel because it's it's that's very new
to me it's not ringing a bell excited
about the furious about fury of the deep
getting an animated remake um yeah I'm
not as I'm not as high on the animated
remakes I think as some people are I
like them I like that they exist but you
know they're just kind of there for me
yeah cool I'm that's a I'm glad they do
that but you know I don't exactly get
pumped for them I had to go to the
doctor last week because my ankle wasn't
pain to where I was limping
turns out I strained some muscles I have
to wear insoles to help alleviate the
pain ow oh jeez Connor I hope that
shorts out soon
I doubt you have but have you ever seen
dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde that was on ITV
um no probably not
are there any poets in particular you'd
recommend oh jeez I don't know I'm not a
poetry buff um I'm not I'm not really a
person to ask if I'm being completely
honest I heard Blanche from Pokemon go
was confirmed as non-binary so that's
something good I've got to look out who
Blanche is cuz I probably should know
that cuz might my kid is now into
Pokemon go where that's gonna be really
fun with the weather getting cold
where I am but um but yeah she's diggin
the heck out of it I like to the point
that I've got her account on my phone
she doesn't have a smartphone but she
has her account loaded up on both my
phone and her mother's phone and if I'm
in an area that has polka stops I won't
catch anything for her but I will stop
and get her more balls and all the other
stuff oh that sounds awful I'm getting
balls for my child ah I subscribed to
the Council of geeks mostly for Doctor
Who but I'm glad I can also gain
knowledge about the lgbtqa+ community
I'm very passionate about it even though
I'm straight that is wonderful to hear
thank you very much did you see
hocus-pocus to is official I mean it it
is but don't jump the gun cuz the here's
the thing like they have a screenwriter
on it
but you need to understand that that
means that they're serious about it but
a screenwriter is not the same as a
green light and even a green light is
not the same as people have signed on
the dotted line to actually do it so
it's headed in the direction of
happening but it's still at a very early
point the process I'm pretty sure this
thing has had screenwriters assigned to
it at least once before so just don't
don't go nuts is all I'm saying
are you a poet and don't know it no I
know I'm not a poet I mean like
sporadically and like weird capacities
Star Wars the Mandalorian trailers
awesome that's actually going to be the
next video on from of geeks after I'm
done here
I've already shot a reaction video to
that and that's gonna go up on there
today Shh my father and I might go see
that new war movie Midway that's coming
on next week I'd be interested to see
what it offers
I haven't heard of that either I'm not
big on war movies like just as a genre
it's not really for me so I that wasn't
one I'd even heard of ah is your
daughter more of a reader or a video
audio media girl she's a pretty good mix
right now she does enjoy reading I've
gotten I've gotten her onto graphic
novels now I hey I had to hunt to find
something that she really dug but she is
really enjoying the princeless graphic
novels she digs those quite a bit but
yeah no she she enjoys reading and Jane
she's a very good she like reads like
two three grades above you know a grade
level two or three higher than she
actually is so hey I new hope you have a
happy Halloween I hope you do as well
I just what are you being for Halloween
well so you remember how I mentioned my
kids gotten into Pokemon and Pokemon go
well she decided she's going to be
Pikachu
which means I'm gonna be ash ah got this
cheap Jack costume gonna stuff my hair
up I into the hat and we're gonna have a
long just like a thermal shirt
underneath the dang thing but yeah
that's uh that's what I'll be doing on
Halloween how would a sequel to
hocus-pocus works since the black flame
candle can only work once you're
seriously asking how are they gonna
bring back the characters in a story
that literally has resurrection magic
like the rules are made up they can make
up a new exception undo way for them to
come back what do you think about HBO
canceling the game of Thrones prequel
did they actually hadn't heard that what
I did hear about today was the UM the
the guys from Game of Thrones the Star
Wars movie that they were working on
that fell apart and they walked away
from that which huh that's gotta sting
especially because it really did feel
like Game of Thrones was rushed so that
they could start working on all this
other stuff they'd closed deals for and
now that's not happening either it's
like you buggers and that's like some
position we don't know for sure if that
was why they decided to wrap up at the
point they did but it really did feel
like it didn't it
thoughts on Homestuck don't know this
might be too personal so feel free to
ignore what is your daughter dressing up
oh I already said uh-huh
a word reboot series is coming I have
been seen the original do you need to do
oh just quick shout out to Karen who is
doing awesome on the troll slayage
this time around nicely done
do you read webtoons they just saw one
of the comics I follows being adapted
into a series by the Jim Henson Company
um I used to read like the webcomic got
I really dug for a while with sluggy
freelance witch
I haven't gotten back to in years but I
I don't really read anything online
anymore these days it's just it's just
time I got too much other stuff as you
drop has your daughter ever seen the
labyrinth haha yes my daughter has seen
labyrinth she enjoys the fireese quite a
bit and she's also seen the Dark Crystal
she loves fizzgig gotta catch them all
candy
you're kidding sounds so cute I hope you
take pictures of your ash costume I will
and like it'll be slightly embarrassing
for me because I'm not I'm you know I'm
not gonna put up pictures of my kid on
you know publicly viewable social media
but I'll put up what I'm gonna be in
much to my shame let's see
one of my favorite fun facts about
labyrinth is one of the fireese was
played by the guy who plays cat a red
dwarf Oh Danny John Jules he has an
interesting filmography that guy the
things we do for our kids
oh god yeah that's uh uh-huh and that's
the truth
would you rather be another character
from Pokemon see the thing is pokemons
not my fandom so for me to even dresses
anybody from Pokemon is is me stepping
outside of you know my zone so the by
its nature something I'm doing for my
kid that's not to say I don't know about
Pokemon but like Pokemon I'm a I'm just
slightly too old for Pokemon because
because it was a you know it was a mid
late 90s that it really started blowing
up and I wasn't watching cartoons
anymore at that point I played the
original game like original original on
the Gameboy um
and I liked it well enough but you know
I never got into it never played the
card game have you watched watch him out
on HBO nope funny and funnily enough
nobody's really been on me too either
you're like not many people have asked
for my thoughts on that which is kind of
a slight relief for me because the vibe
I got off it was so bleak I kind of
don't wanna watch it all that much um
that's not it's not because I don't
think it looked good although I have my
concerns I had critiques and of just the
trailers I'm like I don't know about
that but like more than anything just
the tone I don't think is where I want
to be my headspace well I'm looking
forward to but right now is the next
season - Shira I'm pumped for that you
are never too old for Pokemon gotta buy
them all oh boy yeah I'm getting a
switch for Pokemon and so are a lot of
my friends were 24 239 I mean my
daughter got into it because of
- Pikachu ah it's great very dark a
comical well I mean sounds the original
work but again I wouldn't read the
original Watchmen for pleasure either
when I was a freshman in high school I
was introduced to a Disney movie called
never cry wolf it's a very nuanced film
a beautiful direction of pacing I
recommend it for sure I have seen that
I've seen that movie I saw that in
middle school I think that is a good
movie Watchmen appeared to be the first
decent thing Lindelof ever did oh oh
that's harsh do you think there should
be more non binary options and video
games like being able to choose he see
them yeah you know what I'd actually
like to see a lot more of them do I
would like to see more games that have a
male/female option for customized
protagonist is do what Saints Row 2 did
and instead of having gender be options
click this click this click this it's a
slider bar so like males over here
females over here and you decide where
you're gonna be but yeah like I don't
think there's any real reason to not
implement non-binary options unless the
narrative of the story you're telling in
some way is deeply impacted by the
gender of the characters because
sometimes that's true but first of all
it has to be a narrative based game for
that to even be applicable and a lot of
the big triple-a games these days are
not narrative space no matter what they
say and so there's no reason to not have
non binary options so yeah I would like
them to
I might dress this Arthur Dent for
Halloween I'm just too lazy to do
anything else yeah you just slap on a
bathrobe and look confused the whole
time ask if anyone has tea that's that's
an easy one
and have a towel oh well yes you always
have to know where your towel is for
Halloween when you were younger um I had
a lot of fun when I was a ninja one year
but I wasn't like super in love with
with any of my costumes
Peyer just has it as an option in the
menu you could change anytime with an
option for they though in that case the
players never seen well that always
makes it easier but still again like in
a case like that there's no reason not
to so just go ahead just have that as an
option American Horror Story yay your
name well you need to realize I I have
only seen the first five seasons and I'm
not found the time to see anything past
that so first season pretty good second
season love it third season crap fourth
season liked it quite a bit fifth season
crap so it's it's very up and down um
and I also think what seasons you like
are gonna vary depending on your
personal tastes in horror so like the
reason I love season two is that it hit
my sweet spot because if you're gonna
unnerve me mental health the degradation
of one's mental state that's on that's a
soft spot for me in terms of if you're
going to weird me out and unnerve me and
I don't necessarily want to experience
that level of unnerving but thankfully
because of the kind of camp level that
American Horror Story tends to take it
to it managed to tickle that unnerving
sense a little bit while still being big
and bombastic and operatic enough where
it didn't like shake me to my core cuz I
don't want that too often I need to take
that in measured doses but I really did
like asylum that was the best season by
far for me I know what the people have
other views like um my daughter's mother
her favorite was the first one by far
because she loves ghosts and that's her
sweet spot so you know I think that will
really
the impact how you feel about these
things I really do think coven was
garbage though I'm a bad feeling that we
won't get a second season of Dark
Crystal can I even want to reassure me i
I can't reassure you I am NOT loving the
fact that we don't have word of a second
season yet and I said this at the time
when I when I wrapped up my review of
the first season that we can't count on
a second season this was expensive to do
and I really hope we get one more season
but you know then again
Netflix can't drag its feet on official
announcements season four stranger
things only officially got announced
like a few weeks ago so you know it's
not like all hope is gone
but it's not a foregone conclusion that
we'll get it excited for doctors sleep
and what's your perspective on the
shining book or movie oh boy um I don't
know what to think about dr. sleep I've
never read oh okay I've never read a
Stephen King book I've tried his writing
style doesn't really do it for me I've
liked some of the movies based off some
of the stuff I think the shining is one
of the most overrated movies in the
history of cinema half awake and mostly
asleep hello well hello to you too
Edward much appreciated I'm still vexed
they cancelled the gifted but at least
we have Orville yeah I never got around
to trying the gifted and we thought some
seasons 6a a bow Jack no I don't watch
bow Jack I do not want to be that
depressed not really sure about keeping
Netflix after Oh hold on ah lost it
after Bojack horseman wraps up I mean
you know that's that's people's call
unsubscribe great tea sip what yeah yeah
that's that's that's one of my more
controversial opinions and lookee here
here's the thing about The Shining
whenever people tell me why they think
it's good it all comes down to the
production and the meticulousness of its
composition and I will grant it all of
that it is a Emmy for god sakes it's a
Kubrick film it is a meticulously
plotted structured execute especially on
a visual level film but a high level of
craft can only polish a turd to such a
shine it's not a good movie they
executed it about the they executed what
they wanted to do with that story about
as well as it could possibly be done but
what they were doing with that story
wasn't good and that's not me being a
book furious because again I don't read
the book but there are basically like
two scenes that I'll tip my hat to on
that and other than that it's a
meticulously filmed and executed waste
of time
for me in my opinion does your daughter
watch any of the old 1992-2000 Disney
Channel original movies I don't think
she has ever seen any of those Tiffany
does I I don't even know I was out of it
by then so I wouldn't have passed those
on to her and I don't have like the
Disney Channel in you know come into the
house or she wouldn't catch that on
reruns turns out David Lynch - right -
the Disney movie called the straight
story oh yeah I know about the straight
story yeah I'm well aware of that one
that's that's the old one out in David
Lynch's filmography by uh by quite a
margin
my family's weird both my sisters and I
laugh at the shining The Shining is
funny that's part of why it's not good
though because it's supposed to be scary
and I'm sorry it's not like at all and
that's like the big measure of a horror
film
does it scare you and the whole not even
close
was the shiny meant to be scary because
I thought it was a comedy there you go
see I'm not the only one The Shining
book was bait was way better I've heard
that but I'm not I'm not gonna make that
statement I can't back it up
how jump-scare based is American Horror
Story um I'm actually not sure because
it's been a long time since I've seen
the seasons that I that I've seen like
my memory and the stuff that stuck out
to me none of it was jump scares but
jump scares also tend to fade to the
back of my memory and that's the kind of
stuff I tend to forget was ever in a
movie at all
so I actually don't know thoughts on a
Clockwork Orange
I lucked Clockwork Orange is one of only
two um Kubrick movies that I actually
like
it's Clockwork Orange and it's dr.
Strangelove
I don't like any other Kubrick movie
I've seen at least not all the way
through I like the middle third of 2001
a Space Odyssey the beginning goes on
too long and the ending is nonsense
stupid question why didn't the doctor go
to Canada in 1938 or close by and get
Amy and Rory a taxi cab to the TARDIS
and bring them home because then it's
not painfully tragic there becomes a
certain point where you need to stop
asking those logistical questions
because the emotional impact is the
point of the story and you cover your
bases you know your plot hole base is
just enough so that it doesn't break the
reality of the narrative to have the
payoff for that but like at a certain
point you need to accept the answer it
is because if he did that then we don't
have the emotional story that we have
sometimes you need to just accept the
meta
I like Full Metal Jacket that's another
one with sections that are good
Zombieland DoubleTap was really good I
was surprised how much I liked that um I
did enjoy Zombieland DoubleTap quite a
bit
that said I mm-hmm about the day after
is about what's about rosario dawson her
and stuff that she's accused of came out
so you know I'm kind of in a sour spot
on it but that's not the movies fault I
recently watched 2001 for the first time
since it originally ran it's an
experience I don't care to repeat ah do
you have hard cider in that Cup um I am
I have apple cider which may or may not
contain additional things
ah Lolita was awesome yes that would
that was Kubrick um I haven't actually
see I look to be fair I haven't seen
every Kubek movie I've seen enough of
them to know I just don't like the guys
work so no I haven't sought out and seen
all of them so I also haven't seen Eyes
Wide Shut hey someone's like hey a
council of geeks hey I don't know what
you want me to do with that friends made
me watch Full Metal Jacket when my
husband went to USMC boot camp I didn't
mind the first bit but then it got but
then got bored yeah pretty much with
that one do you enjoy cheesy cheesy 80
slasher films I really don't I I really
really don't I like some of the UM later
self were sequels to some cheesy slasher
sounds like I legitimately love Wes
Craven's new nightmare I think that's a
great movie and I get a lot of fun it's
dumb but I get a lot of fun out of Jason
X
but 80 slasher it's just like in my mind
unless you are either of gore hound or
you subscribe to the so bad it's good
philosophy of viewing which I don't I
just can't get into that headspace
unless it's with a large group of
friends and appropriate beverages so
yeah it's not really my thing have you
seen a film called the last Mimzy no I
haven't seen that one going is the
Eighth Doctor following oh cool
uh Sam falling behind as I tend to do
love you so much for your catchy turn of
phrase well thank you very much
wish I knew what I said to set that off
or maybe you mean in general I'm not
sure I'm that eloquent but I I'm just
rambling I think every now and then I
accidentally stumble across a you know a
nice gem but it's it's something that
happens by happenstance because when you
talk as much as I talk eventually you'll
say something decent just law of
averages but if there's masses of plot
holes in the emotional angle you're
going for is cheapen like the episode is
not one particularly well because of the
plot problems I mean Maury and like
everyone everyone has their own
threshold for the willful suspension of
disbelief some people have that Thresh
threshold is a very high bar they need
like a real plot hole three story
otherwise it takes them out of it
completely um I I mean I'm a theatre
person I have a pretty high threshold
for willful suspension of disbelief and
if the emotional impact works without me
in the moment while watching it if I
don't go wait a minute then as far as
I'm concerned as
his job if it's like later like a day
later or a week later or a month later
that I'm like hey on couldn't they have
done this and it takes me that long for
it to occur to me and that didn't happen
in the moment of watching it for the
first time then that's fine because I
have my video on plot holes and why I
don't care about them I only care about
plot holes that that break it while I'm
watching it Platteville's that I only
spot in hindsight I don't care I guess I
just don't have you seen the boys man
okay look I'm we're adding that to the
drink question is list I swear to God
every time have you seen the boys no
oh boy um I refuse to talk about Lolita
legit back in the day my best friend and
I would dress up in costumes and go
watch one of the Saw movies every
Halloween like just generic costumes or
saw costumes specifically you would do
are you enjoying the new season of the
goods place I am behind on it I need to
catch up speaking of the Eighth Doctor
there's also a significant role of Paul
McGann and the series called Hornblower
for the BBC I've heard of that series
I've never seen it going as a witch with
a few Hufflepuff accents oh that's
another thing I I can brag about so on
Halloween the at my kids school kids
can't wear costumes but it has to be a
storybook character which I suspect is
their way of ensuring that you know some
of the older kids don't come dripping in
gore and looking like murderers so she
my kid now has her wizard robes and a
scarf in Gryffindor colours cuz that's
her house I am a Slytherin raising a
Gryffindor that this is my life
dating a Ravenclaw and my kids mother's
a Hufflepuff I've got the full spectrum
covered if you were the doctor what
original costume would you invent for
yourself I don't have a short answer
right now that is something that I am
kind of working on I want to come up
with my own version of a doctor's outfit
it needs to have a coat that goes at
least down to the knee like that's a
must I want something that looks plain
over the coat shop but underneath is
more colorful beyond those broad
conceptual strokes I don't have it
nailed down yet theatre person Sondheim
opinions
I mean Sondheim's very good at what he
does
I don't know his entire thing I mean
when I say a theater person I don't mean
like I'm educated in theater and give
you a lecture on theater I mean like
theater was my favorite thing to do when
I was in high school kid kept doing
theater in college I enjoyed going to it
I enjoyed performing in it did community
theater the reason I brought it up is
because in theater there's a there's a
very strong need for willful suspension
of disbelief because you're looking at a
set it doesn't look real and you have to
be much more accepting and that carries
over to my film feeling I just met John
Barrowman this weekend it was so awesome
I shook his hand and nervously told him
I loved him as well you should have
Jimmy he is a very cool person that was
I I was really glad to get to meet him
um earlier this year back in August I'm
oh dear Ben I have a bone to pick with
you
another live stream you agreed with
someone who said lilo and Stitch was
overrated how dare you not love the same
things as me I I I humbly prostrate
myself before you for the sin of calling
something that you love overrated it's
okay
I loved I loved treasure planet and
nobody defends that so
yeah discord yes I will get to the
discord in just a minute Thank You
Carolyn
got any Halloween TV shows minor young
Dracula demon head bastard no like
specific episodes like I'll probably pop
in the some of the Halloween episodes
from Buffy usually something saw themed
I guess you could say we were covered in
fake blood and weird stuff like that
honestly surprised the theater never
stopped us I'm kind of surprised too
especially if you were covered in fake
blood they were they would have had to
have cleaned the seat I've worked in a
theater I would like to see a Timelord
campaign I wanted Missy to be the next
companion I wanted one more series out
of Capaldi Missy being the companion I'm
still bitter that we didn't get that I
defend Treasure Planet good fight the
good fight are you familiar with Sarah Z
I am familiar with Sarah Z I have
supported her on patreon
Gryffindor's of slytherins are just two
sides of the same coins some ways
there's there's a lot to clash over ever
saw road to El Dorado I did chemistry
between the two leads was amazing looked
very pretty story was okay best way to
reveal the next doctor would be to have
someone wanderer a con in costume that
when asked who they are they say they're
the doctor and ask what year it is that
would be very cool
okay I got a pop over to the discord
real quick and see what questions got
asked over there because as a reminder
plug the discord for council of geeks is
a patreon exclusive perk and people who
there is a channel for questions on the
lead up to the live streams and
questions asked there I do
guarantee we'll get answered so let me
pull that up here we go let me see here
um hocus-pocus - talked about that it
was a bit of a conversation about the
word spoopy which I had fun reading back
and forth there wasn't really a question
directed at me out of that though so
I'll I'll move on from that for
Halloween me and my friends tried to
pull together a Brooklyn nine-nine style
Halloween ice took us two minutes to
realize how bad of an idea that was yeah
that's the kind of stuff that like would
be fun to plan and a disaster to execute
I mean just just watch the show cuz man
that shows good I know how the heist
episodes are so good we've got Nightmare
Before Christmas lyrics my significant
other and I will probably be on
trick-or-treat greeting duty this year
even though I really don't like
Halloween oh oh that that's stinks it's
by in the town where I live really not
too many people hand out candy anymore
because everything is concentrated on
Main Street like the houses there I know
they're they're big houses you know with
people who you know don't mind being on
on the Main Street and that's where the
Halloween parade goes through so at this
point that's where the vast majority of
trick-or-treating happens and like the
the streets the further away you get
from Main Street the less people are
actually doing trick-or-treating on
those streets so what's your favorite
horror movie um I mean scariest movie is
the invasion of the Body Snatchers 1978
I've mentioned that more than a few
times I mean some other ones I really
like I like the descent
I like Pan's Labyrinth there are others
I uh I tend to draw up a woman in black
that's a good one
most memorable costume he did when you
were little I answered that one
difference between cosplaying dressing
up for Halloween when I was little there
was no cosplay as there is now not named
that way at least there was always dress
up and stuff like that of course there's
always Halloween but what exactly makes
it cosplay over just dressing up as far
as I'm concerned nothing like there are
there are some people different people
will give you different definitions some
people will tell you cosplay is what
happens at conventions in my mind if you
are representing a character that you
love regardless of whether you made the
costume bought the costume from someone
who knows how to make that bought the
costume in a bag that's cosplay as far
as I'm concerned and there really isn't
a difference the only difference is sort
of the intent we because with Halloween
you're wearing the costume to facilitate
something else you know ie the
trick-or-treating and it's kind of
embedded into the holiday whereas I
think generally people usually use
cosplay for scenarios in which wearing a
costume is a complete and utter choice
it's 100% optional whereas Halloween
there's an expectation where you know
there's plenty of people in costume in
like a con or whatever but no one's
expected to be in costume it's just very
cool that they are like that might be
the only difference but in terms of
approach no difference what are you
giving out to trick-or-treaters not a
thing because I got to walk my kid
around what's your favorite candy aside
from black licorice
it varies I'm partial more - I've really
moved away from chocolate as I've gotten
older I still like dark chocolate and
white chocolate a bit but milk chocolate
especially I've moved away from but you
know at this point I tend to favor
things like skittles Spri starbursts
sort of that sort of area favorite non
scary Halloween movie ParaNorman almost
done with the discord and then I'm
coming back I promise what would be
creepier a Steve banning costume or a
see Steve Bannon costume ha that is not
fair to put that in my head Oh what
horror movie do you think isn't scary
that everyone else thinks is scary
besides the shining I mean that's the
big one off the top my head um I don't
know like I don't I lose track of what
people actually think is scary
especially considering so many horror
movies they're their big pitch isn't
scares it's something else like the AV
slasher movies a great example none of
those are actually scary it's a great
question but I don't know an answer and
finally no one expects the Spanish
Inquisition and a Monty Python gif yes
because it's gif it's not jiff
huh I will die on that hill
thoughts on the movie Coraline it's good
um I still haven't read the original
book but having read actually for the
tough like a girl podcast having read a
graphic novel graphic novel adaptation
that is very faithful to the original
book I've realized how completely
unnecessary the character of Y B is and
I can't unknow that so that has soured
the movie for me slightly but it's still
really good movie oh let's see
are you familiar with dark place i nope
that does not bring about just what she
were all the way through my favorite
characters adora just after she's been
infected by the red first one tech or as
I call her drunk adora ah I love that
show I rewatched that episode recently
that's a great episode and I really do
like I'll uh she runs into score he's
like wow you're a big bug and of course
I like Skorpio oh I love Scorpius so so
so so much
I asked John this John Barrowman I asked
John if he would give Chibnall a call
for if he could give Jim melic all for
returning to Doctor Who and he said as
soon as someone gives me his number
that's a very John Barrowman
a response I think I'll Chuck sweets out
of the window yelling watch your heads
best impression of my own accent well
that's plan
who remembers the cheap costumes of the
80s with the plastic masks and gown the
ones that fell apart before you got
through the block but ones that we're
basically just colored trash bags with a
plastic mask
I remember those never had to wear one
but I do remember those licorice is
gross licorice is great you know what my
favorite though you got to go to like
health food service find this but it's
pandal the brand is like panda licorice
and they were there red licorice oh
that's that's childhood to me right
there
have you seen neon genesis evangelion i
have not and as with most animes it is
intimidating to even try and figure out
how favorite Harry Potter films score oh
I don't know I haven't listened to them
in isolation I probably have to pick the
differences out enough went to MCM Comic
Con last weekend they had real Doctor
Who props and costumes including the
ninth and 10th doctor I'm assuming you
mean their costumes as opposed to just
having them there as if they were props
did you watch scary stories to tell in
the dark I did not see that one have you
noticed a Sea Hawk and Scorpio are
besties without even realizing it I have
I do like Sea Hawk a lot - he so just
wants to be cool and he's not and that's
a heck of a well-groomed mustache though
favorite Scooby Doo incarnation um the
one from a couple of like a decade ago I
guess now it was like I'd even what's
new Scooby dude
no it wasn't what's new I can't remember
now but it had more of an ongoing plot
and Velma was dating shaggy that one was
good
I just love I just love the fact that
favorite Scooby Doo incarnation is even
a valid question to be asked that's
funny to me top three or two if it's too
much as scary movies you want people to
know about because you think they're not
mentioned enough um scooby-doo mystery
Inc thank you um okay horror movies
people that don't get mentioned enough
not enough people saw annihilation now
that that's an existential horror movie
um trying to think what else there's
probably others just drawn a blank at
the moment that was the only way I could
come up with Scooby Doo regenerates more
than the doctor valid when I was a kid I
never really clicked with a midnight
decide from finding it a bit creepy now
that I'm studying psychology I find it
fascinating and really terrifying
Midnight's a great episode of Doctor Who
it really really is I still need to
watch anihilation yeah be in the right
headspace if you're gonna watch
annihilation cuz that is a trip of a
movie and I don't mean like you can't
follow what's going on cuz you can but
like that movie messes with you like
when I first came out of the theater I
didn't know if I liked it or not cuz I
just had to process and that took about
a week that's the kind of movie
annihilation is how do you tell if
someone is gatekeeping uh practice
mostly like there aren't there aren't
hard and fast rules where if someone
does this they are being gatekeeping
it's just it it's the same way how I I
have to give assurance sometimes when I
go off on people you know who asked me
questions about my gender presentation
or my sexuality that and that you know I
usually try and be helpful but some
people I go often and they're like they
were just asking a question like no they
weren't just asking a question
well how do you know because I've been
answering these questions and talking to
people like this for long enough that I
just know and I can't really quantify
that for you if you don't just know and
it's kind of the same thing with
gatekeeping behavior so everyone knows
how the Grinch Stole Christmas but did
you know there's actually a Grinch
Halloween movie it's called Halloween is
Grinch night yes I love Halloween is
Grinch night it's really good
oh I grew up on that I had that on VHS
taped off the TV by my grandmother I say
I remember the songs I oh I wouldn't go
out on a night like this for a dollar
and fifty cents which Doctor Who story
do you feel is the best for Halloween um
I would say depends on your Halloween
mood you want something more campy go
for mummy on the Orient Express if you
want genuinely creepy go with midnight
um if you want creepy but more uplifting
maybe empty child have you seen this new
bag pose new video on Doctor Who's state
also have you gotten around to checking
out his Fifty Shades review yet I I
still I keep forgetting to do his Fifty
Shades review um but I did see his video
on Doctor Who and that's kind of fair
funnily enough that's kind of where I am
with Star Wars right now not for quite
the same reasons but ya know I could
relate to what he was saying I totally
got where he was coming from with that
Halloween is Grinch night and so is so
weird but I totally recommend everyone
watching it at least once you have you
can get it definitely watch
I wonder if there's something about
being neuro atypical that affects how
disturb someone is by a movie I'm
usually too fascinated by films like
annihilation to find it creepy well I
mean it depends on the nature of your
neuro a typicality if that is in fact a
word which it might not be but yeah you
know different people are wired
different ways different people find
different things unnerving there are
things that creep the heck out of me
that don't bother other people there are
things that creep the heck out of other
people that don't bother me I thought it
was very unscary because I don't find
clowns creepy and I don't think the
horror stands up beyond a few jump
scares if you don't find clowns
inherently creepy so you know different
things impacted people different ways
that's true of anything not everyone
cries at the same things it's not
everyone laughs at the same thing static
what's scared by the same things and
that's not the same neuro being neuro
atypical doesn't play a factor in that
I'm sure it does but I'd be careful
about putting too much weight on that
being a root cause cuz as they say
there's no accounting for taste I'm
literally getting those questions about
my sexuality since I came out it's
annoying yeah yeah yeah again like you
just you just know after a while when
someone's not asking you sincerely
they're asking you in wording it in a
way that they're trying to get you into
a logic trap so that they can invalidate
you like as a person mm-hmm
do you think we will get another Vincent
and the doctor do you mean another one
like that touching I don't know or do
you mean another one there's gonna talk
about kind of issues because maybe I
mean I know for some people Rosa
was that powerful it wasn't for me but I
know some some folks found that so
Austin CW confirming an or to order a
Superman and Lois
series Oh are they is it with the
Superman and Lois that have been
introduced in those in those series
because I'd be down for that I do need
to wrap up soon let me try and hand
let's see one of my favorite works of
error of animation is the world of Eric
Carle and anthology of animation show
it's based on the books of Eric Carle
it's so well made it deserves to be
watched I will I will not be surprised
if liz has seen that scooby-doo mystery
Inc had the most plot driven overall arc
with cursed treasure and Town Crystal
Cove having curses on it yeah that was
the one it's kind of sad that chip knows
best dr. script ended up being an
anticlimactic epilogue to the Angels
Take Manhattan DVD I forgot that he
wrote PS but that's kind of says it all
doesn't it he writes on assignment he's
he's a gig writer he's not a visionary
which was kind of Stu bag pulls point in
his video and I think he kind of nailed
that only thinking that will get me in a
movie is an old person's death or an
animal's death nothing else Oh pets
dying is oh that's the worst can you
actually watch the Grinch
one here on YouTube for free not a clue
like I said I had old beat-up v8 just
copy and I haven't seen that in years
free watch loving monsters do you reckon
part of what doesn't work about it not
the main reason is that it isn't a very
Doctor Who plot blink still felt like
Doctor Who um except it is a Doctor Who
plod just viewed from a very strange
angle because it's an alien that
infiltrates a group of humans and is
with a grudge against the doctor that's
I mean at its bare bones it's a fairly
Doctor Who plot it's just a very not
doctor who approached to that plot which
one could you know makes
claims about with link as well but like
there's just a lot wrong with love and
monsters has anyone on here met Robert
Downey jr. or Jeremy Renner nope
can I say that I have alright so I am
thinking we're gonna wrap up in a minute
or let's see horror movie kills a person
me whatever horror movie kills a pet me
how dare you you monsters yeah yeah
pretty much
I'm still trying explain to my mom what
non-binary means also one of my friends
told me non-binary was under the
umbrella of trans is that true it is
because now yeah you want to be careful
with that because that is contested with
some people there in fighting within the
lgbtq+ community and in fighting within
the trans made it community specifically
bums me right the heck out but it is the
thing so but yet broadly speaking
non-binary is part of trans because you
are transitioning away from whatever you
were assigned at birth because nobody's
assigned non-binary at Birth so you have
transitioned away from something and
into something else it's not a standard
binary transition and you would want to
avoid calling yourself a trans man or
trans woman because that means something
much more specific ie you're describing
what you transition to in July if you
transitioned into non-binary yes that
does follow a fall under the umbrella of
trans but again it's it gets slightly
dicey depending on who you're talking to
because some people are weird
oh thanks James James complimented
Caroline on doing a great job moderating
which she does and you gave me courage
to be more expressive oh that's great to
hear James mm excuse me my brother's
wife her plan to take their kids to the
grinch CG or were planning to take their
kids to the grinch CG movie but then
while I was shopping I ended up buying
the original anime special and that was
enough well yeah that is enough cuz it's
great you once mentioned that Promethea
is on the docket for tough like a girl
but didn't find anything is my search
foo bad or didn't you get to it yet we
haven't gotten to Prometheus yet that's
probably gonna wait until summer because
it's it's Alan Moore so it's a dense
read so we're probably gonna wait until
is isn't having to worry about classes
as much is non-binary trans yes or knows
to binary of an answer yeah yeah you
nailed it
my least favorite is Sleep No More
because mainly we're on a space station
everyone thinks they're fine but it's
actually super sleep-deprived is such a
good horror concept like there were
there were some hints of good ideas and
Sleep No More I really don't think it
worked though sorry if this is too
personal haha I'm sure I'll answer it
anyway but how did you figure out who
you were attracted to I never asked a
person out and I'm worried I won't know
the feeling if when I do like someone I
mean I don't know how to explain what it
feels like to be attracted to someone
like my crushes were pretty much almost
always on women
I've only had sporadic few crushes on
men over the years and it's just you
know it's just it's just a feeling like
who do I feel a pull to Who am I like I
want to spend more time with this person
and not just like hang out like I I want
I want to do things to this person
because I mean that look I'm not trying
to be skeezy but that's what attraction
is that doesn't mean that you you do
stop you know consent and then
everything else super important but like
a display some of us what attraction is
and I always felt that pull I could tell
who that was towards and I identify at
this point as pansexual but like with
the caveat that I lean very heavily
towards female presenting people but
that's not a 100% to the exclusion of
everything else it's just a strong
preference so yeah again not too
personal like I I don't think there's
been a question that's really I would
have considered too personal unless it
unless it's about my kid because uh you
know her privacy is something that I'm
not gonna give up to other people so I'm
called Steven Moffat the Frank Miller of
Doctor Who do you think that is a fair
assessment well no because Frank Miller
is a xenophobic racist so no it's not a
fair comparison that's the thing like
it's not just a man I assume that the
person who said that was trying to make
the point like once-great lost their
touch but Frank Miller didn't just lose
his touch Frank Miller went nuts and
like hit the stuff he has worked on post
9/11 which to be fair he was in New York
when that happened and I understand that
that affected him deeply
but like the stuff he's written since
then is
it's damaging and it's hurtful and
whatever you think about Steven Moffat
he doesn't write hate speech Frank
Miller has so you know no I don't think
it's a fair comparison at all because
while you can say comparably they both
used to be great went off the end and
got worse the ways in which they got
worths
are simply different one simply bought
into his old own - is not as quite as
clever as he thinks he is at least not
all the time the other became a gross
human being so ya know III would not
make that comparison just want to let
you know you look absolutely wonderful
thank you so much personal question
personal computer or Mac I have a PC III
that's what I grew up on and I stick
with what I know and that's not because
I think they're better than max is
because I don't want to learn how to use
something else Steven Moffat gender
politics are terrible yes but not out of
whack with the gender politics of his
line of perfect so like this is gonna be
a weird comparison it's it's almost like
the HP Lovecraft conversation when you
talk about his racism and some people
will defend him but saying that he
wasn't racist by the standards of the
time except he was even for the time HP
Lovecraft was really racist
and whereas was Steven Moffat
yeah his gender politics kind of suck
but he doesn't build a story around
pushing his gender politics he doesn't
his gender politics suck out of
ignorance as opposed to hate
whereas Frank Miller's worst writing
holy terror being the absolute worst
but his worst writing is bad because he
is writing with the intention of pushing
his hate through a narrative as opposed
to his ignorance about something and his
failure to pay attention to the choices
he's making and what that says that's
that that doesn't make it okay but
that's an error of ignorance as opposed
to a forced error of hatred and there is
a difference and that's not to let
Steven Moffat off the hook because yeah
sometimes his gender politics freaking
suck have you watched Jekyll it's really
messed up through that lens but he it's
the difference between not knowing
better and trying to actively convince
everyone else that your hatred is right
that's the difference between Steven
Moffat and Frank Miller if you're trying
to make any kind of comparison along
those lines I don't know if my gender is
best described as non-binary or woman I
know I feel comfortable in whichever the
answer is I just can't make up my mind
and that is valid as well that's why I
embrace gender fluid I am not nailed
down not in that way anyways oh I've got
saucy
hey you're still streaming I didn't miss
the entire stream no you didn't I keep
saying I'm gonna wrap it up and I keep
being here cuz I'm having a good night
I've been researching non-binary to
understand it more from what there was
awareness of the group in the 80s then
why do people treat non-binary as if
it's a new thing well because the
terminology didn't hit the mainstream
until relatively recently and that is
actually pretty standard for any like
queer you know representation or
understanding it at all the the ideas
and the concepts within the community
are way older than when the mainstream
tries to wrap their heads around them so
that's part of what's going on with
non-binary and also it just gets lumped
in with a lot of the general political
pushback against the left that's been
going on because the left pushes for
gender and sexual equality it makes them
a prime target for people who want to
push against any or all progressive
leanings so part of it is you know
relatively recent introduction into the
mainstream and part of it is convenient
target for people who are up to
something else I keep meaning to watch
Jekyll I've seen a lot of stuff on
YouTube about it but I can't find it
anywhere Jekyll Jekyll has its moments
that are quite good but as a whole it
really doesn't pull together
I watched Linc Carver's review of
all-star Batman and Robin since reading
that comment that guy who compared
Moffat to Miller is being way too harsh
yeah yeah have you seen the Dracula
series teaser head on over to the break
room of geeks new channel just opened up
check out my reaction video hey hey one
more chance to plug and maybe I will
take that as my
q to wrap up Nathaniel my pearls what
pearls zan dear what hold on have I
missed something
uh what pearls what's going on I'm being
yelled at and I don't know the context
realizing you might be a sexual and
gender fluid in the same year aching and
Xander is clutching their pearl Oh pearl
clutching oh okay good huh I should have
caught that
oh well being yelled at not knowing why
welcome to marriage I'm divorced Pearl's
my birthstone oh cool mine's aquamarine
don't do that look how it turned out for
Martha Wayne yes if your partner ever
gives you a pearl necklace and says
let's take a stroll down this alley
don't do it I think I'm realizing that I
am by philosophy to got me admitting
this oh that's oh wow that's wonderful
that's great to hear Arianna turquoise
topaz oh now now just spouting off
birthstones very cool who's worse off
the Wayne parents are Uncle Ben I mean
they're all dead I mean how is one worse
than the others
sapphire Ruby Wow good stuff ooh diamond
and see now someone collected together
works from your fans would you be
interested in reviewing signal boosting
some of them I will always happily look
at stuff I make no promises about signal
boosting that's something I do kind of
selectively because I don't I don't want
to build a reputation for signal
boosting more than I will be able to
maintain and then not maintaining that
level but if you want to send stuff my
way I will always happily look at it
with no promise of signal boosting
that's a maybe for that part
can't wait till Friday I'm one of those
horrible people starts playing Christmas
music on November 1st Tiffany that is
illegal you are going to get it tickets
maybe you'll get let off for the warning
but keep it up a you will serve time for
that let me have Thanksgiving it's not
Christmas part one do you think you'll
ever rank Sherlock assuming that
remember this that you remember the
series and have been turned into a dog
in your memory um I don't know if it
ever becomes topical I might like if
there's like some if we get another
series or they do a movie special or
something maybe then but otherwise and
probably not isn't that even a felony
depends on the jurisdiction I'm
expecting a couple radio stations to go
all Christmas any day now oh yeah I know
oh man speaking of Moffitt Sherlock has
lost his touch after series 3 while
elementary still remains a good watch I
I bowed out on elementary not because it
wasn't good but because it was hewing
too close to the standard procedural
format
I've just seen too many of those I was
I was knowing who the killer was gonna
be like way early just cuz I know the
formula there are no good Thanksgiving
music so I love them both
alright that's true that's true we are
lacking in Thanksgiving music why does
everyone forget bonfire a night because
it's not really a thing everywhere like
I don't think it's a fan the us at all
so I feel like seeing your reactions to
Tiffany playing Christmas music in
November gave me a glimpse of you in
parent mode yeah maybe a little Hannibal
is my favorite version of Sherlock
because it's like if Watson was Moriarty
and they alternated between trying to
eat and bobeat
that is a sound assessment of that show
that was a good show have you seen
leverage no I caught like a bit of one
episode but that was it any fans of
without a clue I've seen that that's a
fun little variant on Sherlock Holmes
that's that's a cool one I did see some
Christmas themed Target gift cards at
work today when I went to the drugstore
to pick up my milady my prescriptions it
hadn't fully invaded but there was a
Christmas end cap and I did flip it off
when I pass by it
my country doesn't celebrate
Thanksgiving but I'm thankful for this
community oh thank you for that house is
like a medical Sherlock Holmes it is but
also went on too long I work in retail
we've been selling Christmas pajamas for
two weeks oh you know what bugs me okay
look like last thing I really do need it
and you do need to sign off I hate that
Christmas has swallowed up any song that
so much as mentions snow is suddenly a
Christmas song you can't have just a
winter song any episode of a TV show
where there is snow is automatically the
Christmas episode even if Christmas
never comes up it's like the only time
snow has ever acknowledged
like why does Christmas get to just
swallow up every reference to snow
greedy bastard in my defense I at least
don't do any Christmas decorating until
after Thanksgiving okay well that's
something that's a start we can build on
that
it's the capitalism ah capitalism all
right we'll wrap it up there I hope
everybody has a good night I got some
stuff to do check out the break room of
geeks there will be a new video up there
there is a link down in the description
there'll be a new video up to there
later tonight because I got to put up my
reaction to the mandalorian my reaction
to Dracula is already up there other
stuff will be going out there but and of
course regular four videos a week
showing up here as always so that will
that will wrap it up I hope everyone has
a good night I hope you have fun
Halloween if your doing anything and
just remember in the meantime you are
beautiful
you're valid you are loved you are the
council and I'm just running the meeting
have a good night everybody